transgender issues should trans women be
included in feminist conversations how
about in women's spaces yes they're
women
what's the question
trans women are women
no they're not so I I want to come at
this from the position of an athlete oh
Jesus so so I play semi-pro basketball
Semi-Pro volleyball so when it comes to
like athletic spaces I don't think that
trans women should be allowed into
athletic spaces because I don't think
it's a fair
um I think as female athletes we work so
incredibly hard for the little
opportunity there is in women's sports
would this be a barrier like this
there's no barrier there's less
opportunity in some Industries there's
less it's not no no no it's based on the
market okay they won't even let her
speak so again we work very hard for the
little opportunity there is in the space
because we're not as entertaining as the
men sorry we're just not and so it's
like you're going to take the little
opportunity that we're given and the
problem is like
we can't compete we can't like I'm six
foot if I go up against a six foot guy
she's six foot she's gonna body
even if you even if I have years more of
training and so it's like you're taking
away the little opportunity that we're
giving and we all work so hard for and
you're just giving it back to biological
guys it's like this will be the end of
women's sports how are these girls so
pissed oh my God this is I hate watching
this it's just like ruins my day I know
it just ruins my day watching this dumb
it genuinely does like how are
there so many women that that are
arguing these are the feminist women you
think the feminists would want the men
out of their Sport and they're pushing
for men to kick the out of them it
makes no sense they will agree too this
is proof that they will agree to
literally anything that that their
political party that their political
designation puts in front of them if the
Republicans say the sky is blue these
people will fight until the day they die
and say the sky is green and that is all
there is to it and they will die on that
Hill that's what this is this is just
they'll just sit and fight and they
convince themselves so deeply that
they're correct that they are willing to
have men in women's lock this equality
act that the Biden Administration is
actively actively pushing for they're
constantly on social media with quality
act transgender rights which basically
means men who are trans and become women
can then go into women's locker rooms
women's and girls locker rooms restrooms
dressing rooms in in stores where
they're trying on clothes so Grandma
needs to deal with Fred who's now
Francine well she's trying on a dress at
Macy's that's what these people want no
no it's illogical it's unnatural and
it's fine if you want to be trans just
stay just keep the men the actual
biological men out of our that's
all there is to it let's see what let's
see the logic here let's see let's see
please I'm sorry I'm just so aggravating
sorry confidence can't make me bench
with a guy benches
so hostile she's sharing her and
confidence
no she's not she's here she's a woman
who's had no experience
your own experiences and your own
existence And yet when a woman is
sitting here telling you I feel as
though this is unfair and this is
compromising and the situation is not
helping women you guys are like but when
you're like I'm a black person that did
this this and this then it's valid and
fair and viable Eli I want to give you
the chance to respond um so this is
basically a joke of a talking point
everyone has biological advantages in
sports how tall are you uh five eleven
and a half I'm tall I'm five foot eight
I am a trans woman I you would crush me
you would absolutely bone density wrist
strengths we're talking about muscle
density you can't switch those yeah
exactly you would crush me but also Eli
you would never play at the level that
Pearl plays because you would never get
there so let me give you a few more
examples this girl I don't know these
more lactic acid in his body which
caused him to swim better than any of
his competitors this was widely
celebrated and nobody contested it now
just this is in a performance enhancing
hormone
so we all have different bodies this is
a vice video trans woman where do they
find these people
there are I mean every major medical and
every major sports organization agrees
that trans women who have been on
hormones for between one and three years
depending on the organization have the
same competitive abilities that's that
did the study that you're referencing
had like seven people participated by
the way several different studies I'm a
trans woman and a researcher it's
getting personal I don't want it to be a
person live in this space where we're
told that our opinions don't count
because they're not the right kind of
opinions and we're constantly shouted
over and talked over regardless of what
we look like because there's one group
in society that basically takes
precedence and it's frustrating yeah
what I didn't even notice this one over
here they really got the the most
interesting crowd yeah this one is
missing the bottom half of her body this
I don't know what's going on here she
hasn't said anything we had a trip I'm
just earned it's it's frustrating
because when we try to talk about it
we get spooking down too as well so
there's hostility there for plenty years
she's talking about about how
frustrating it is to be condescended
upon as a woman with an opinion and this
other woman is cackling at her laughing
fake laughing so loud over her which is
the most condescending thing you know
they're white women so they have more
privilege so they should yeah
um an opportunity to speak you're
literally a white woman from Australia
you live in a bubble and you're pissed
that voices that have been silenced
forever finally can be heard that's why
I didn't even watch this that
oh it's so funny I didn't even know I
didn't I've never seen this I literally
picked this from my YouTube recommended
that was and this chick well that's how
predictable the is now at this
point isn't it wow you just call what's
gonna happen next I'm like sneako
predicting everything so she's saying
she's mad because these voices are
finally being heard no we're not mad
we're mad that you're not letting us
respond that you're just supposed to
walk in Kick everything off the table
and go I'm a dude and I'm gonna be a
lady now and everybody's going to treat
me like a lady and I want I'm a lady on
my passport and I want ladies bathrooms
and Lady everything and we all just have
to go
okay
no we get to say we get to talk back
sorry pumpkin
literally a white woman Australia you
live in a boat oh my God
she looks so pissed silenced forever
really can be heard that's why they have
the boys because
so they can speak up but we can't
respect bonds this is what they're
saying what did she what did that even
mean they have the voice with they speak
up okay we're having finally can be
heard that's why they have the boy
that's why that's just a completely
pointless comment I don't even
know what she even said I don't even
know what that means something that
they're probably gonna move on from it
as we continue the video because I think
sometimes people just just say words and
they just don't think about the words
they're saying it would have been more
effective if she just like we're having
a conversation about transgender women
participating in sports and I wanted to
allow more people to participate Jordan
I wanted to hear from you so I am not a
professional athlete the closest thing I
have ever done to anything athletic was
I used to do competitive show choir when
I was younger and
um I don't feel really qualified to make
carp long statements about whether or
not trans women should compete in every
kind of sport and I understand that that
is kind of
that's a hard pill to swallow and I just
don't get it like they're feminists and
the feminists hate men but they love the
men that think they're women and they
want them to kick the out of the
other women like it just doesn't make
any sense it's just me my first
inclination is to approach everything
through a lens of inclusivity but at the
same time I also can't speak accurately
to every kind of sport and the different
things that go into it so I really think
in these instances the decisions are
best left up to the professional
governing bodies that dictate these
particular Sports I just feel like
in places these are the same governing
bodies that made kids wear masks while
they played basketball these are the
same governing but that made you get
vaccinated that made super athletes get
vaccinated this is the same governing
body this is yeah all right my ass
listen to them
exactly your opinion doesn't
matter does it if you're not a
professional female athlete or a
Collegiate athlete so like what is this
what this woman just invalidated herself
completely did I miss something no
you're not wrong you're not in your head
over there several times
um
who has the the witch Capital One about
sports this is about
um Freedom like free and equal
participation for transgender people in
social life and the rate sees this as a
socially acceptable way to begin to
remove trans people
whatever the Republican says it does
just start with sports or bathrooms how
dare you suggest that we want to remove
you from society nobody is saying that
we want you out of our children's
schools we want you out of women's
locker rooms because young girls
middle-aged women and old ladies we
don't want you in our rooms you've got a
penis I don't need my grandma seeing
penises and in the locker room at the
gym do you know how horrible and
shocking and uncomfortable that would be
for her hell
because the conversation comes up a lot
well what if we just create an all trans
league right so let's get all the trends
all the men would just kick the out
of the women right all the men would
just kick the out of the women so
that they would have to separate by
biology once again which would take us
right back to where we are now so what
the biological men play with the men and
if you happen to be wearing makeup and a
dress so be it that's your choice but
you are by Nature by God a dude I just
this is just a stupid argument no but
but they have brought this upon us and
as a society this is what we're fighting
about because they they have really dug
deep into the bottom of the barrel to
get things
this is all about power you know what's
crazy is like we fully believe that
we're in the right and like they fully
believe that they're in the right like
they believe they're in the rate just as
much as we believe where in the right is
that crazy to think about imagine we
were the wrong ones about all of this I
know
it is because we believe it just as much
as them because I believe in science and
nature well they believe in science
apparently they just believe in the the
science let's keep going this
isn't sports or bathrooms or locker
rooms something that they find is more
acceptable and then at this point they
start to move into education getting
trans teachers fired Banning trans books
this is a route that is very effective
because it's seen as more acceptable
um but it's also overlooking a lot of
major details like I mean do you all
know how many trans women have won
national titles
who stole that title from women who
fought for the right to have their own
sports leagues how do you how do you
justify that and then call yourself a
woman and a feminist at the same time I
know I'm repeating what you said a
minute ago but the absolute shooting of
One's Own foot well it's funny that Leah
Thomas was a Collegiate or like a
whatever a high tier swimmer as a man
and then goes to the women's league like
that's just hilarious well he couldn't
come near a title as a man oh no no he
was a mediocre cool agents women swimmer
as a man and then he became a woman
a female champion huh interesting if
women's sports were actually going to
end in some way
um I mean it's just not happening
wouldn't you think there would be more
trans women in sports when the majority
of states do allow trans women full
participation International visual so
glad that this person isn't in my real
life foreign
[Laughter]
sexually harassed anymore
we did it guys we sold the problem not
that World
um no I I think obviously the state of
feminism is very much reflected right in
this room but me too for me right in a
particular context means something for
different people it's a different
experience for different people and in
my culture and in my community we're
still working through that there is no
post me too right we're still working
through how do we have these tough
conversations how do we teach not just
you know women but everyone about
consent what does consent look like what
does that look like in our community but
the thing is they're so unrealistic
about consent you know what I mean like
if they were at least realistic about
consent they would make more sense but
they're like you should always ask a
girl before you do anything and it's
like no like let's be honest bro like
you don't ask a girl before you kiss
them you don't like this isn't how life
works like if you were realistic about
and gave good advice maybe it would
help out more than just saying
that girls don't even like girls don't
there's no you have to assume that no
always means no sunny and I'll tell you
this if you're in a relationship where
you're already you're in a long-term
relationship you're already sexually
active and there's a playful no you know
each other well already enough to know
what what you're talking about what's
going on there but if you don't know a
woman well no means no and even
if she she was playing a game with you
like yeah I'm not on the side a man
needs to err on the side of caution I'm
not saying that I don't but I'm saying
if they were realistic about then
they would probably help out more than
if they just gave unrealistic standards
there was nothing that this girl has
said though that is that is so far that
is ridiculous she's saying you know
let's teach young people about consent
now the reason here's here's the problem
the reason you know where again they
break from their own philosophies is
they're over here saying that young
people you and women of all ages and men
need to understand consent because
sexual harm is it is damaging and
traumatic yet at the other time the
other yeah
they want little kids to be taught about
butt plugs and lube and there was a guy
there there was a teacher who was
bragging about teaching that to um
pre-teenagers and there's a there's
another man who was just kicked out of a
school board meeting he was just kicked
out of a school board meeting because he
was reading from a book that the library
just ordered for the school district
which was talking about the wonders of
pornography and masturbation in an
elementary school library so this is so
on the one hand they're saying protect
us from sexual harm and on the other
hand they're pushing sex on little kids
who certainly have no idea how to even
handle that and that was always and is
continues to be considered and proven to
be damaging to children so they don't
really give a if you're saying that
you know trans ideology and over
sexualization of little kids is okay on
the one hand and on the other hand
you're saying don't touch me don't touch
me I'm a woman protect me you really got
you really got your wires crossed let's
see what else she has to say really
going on today man right all those
things that I think it's still very
complicated but I think it starts at the
level of community right of like how do
we have these conversations around
consent Sydney I saw your head up so uh
when the metoo thing was unfolding I was
initially like great I love the idea of
women being able to speak out what's
been really disappointing I suppose for
me post me too is as we're calling it is
that and especially someone who's sort
of on the right wing of Politics as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks I'm all good I I actually would
like to see the rest of that video thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe follow me on Instagram
at sunnyfaz join my Discord and I'll see
you later
[Music]
gone